whittall
ils sont
qui est
on dit
[Musique]
bon
lui valoir michel normandeau serge fiori
45 ans après votre premier disque
harmonium si vous sur le banc si vous
limitez vous l'avez remixé rama stories
et pourquoi alain danse comme le plaisir
de redécouvrir ce piste l'eau sont
extraordinaires comment qu'on a réussi à
faire 104 jojo j'en viens même pot et un
de toutes mes sauts à nos oreilles mais
ce solde de bonheur c'est un grand
plaisir des mini c'est parce qu'on vous
avait promis qu c'est la même chose
d'arriver avec les tables quand on est
faible 1 tandis que c'est la même chose
dans les téléphones présent au mix et on
les aime en réserve x2 alentours nous
c'est vraiment qu'on vient d'initier une
autre album vous avez vendu 125 mais
l'exemple de votre premier disque succès
instantané est ce que vous êtes passés
de pauvres a plus à l'aise ou encore
l'industrie du disque était généreuse
avec ses artistes jamais parce que tout
soit coach a tout le temps partout
alors on se rappellera du chou au sens
partir d'une version de mots rien je
pense que gagné 114 115 moitié des
premiers groupes d'affaires est un
spectacle quadriphonie ok ça a coûté la
peau des fesses pour avoir envie d'avoir
un feu on vient voir avec un peu plus de
savoir fut son assassin qui salue des
pompiers qui sont restés palacin parce
que sa vie ils vous ont dit j'ai avoir
du contenu conquis parce qu'évidemment
je veux aussi retrouver y avait quoi
choquer comme une personne attend
surtout les chagrins exploit n'est qu'un
espace en bout de ligne mais c'est pas
grave on un café s'explique sur l'eau on
a fait ce week end à l'opt a d'ailleurs
nommé x 255 m
démocratie oui mais tout d'argent qu'on
faisait on réinvestit ses dents
production c'est un peu paradoxal parce
qu'en 73 ans monique qui va devenir un
des plus grands groupes indépendantistes
de musique vous avez signé avec une
étiquette une copine disque ontarienne
et vos premières chansons étaient à
manquer quand c'est fait le virage en
français pour moi personnel juge parle
dans mon écriture amour qui se dopent
crée de la musique en france est une
décision très très près qu'on sente mapa
et politique je veux faire de seul angle
là mon instrument
j'espère inspiré des gens socialement et
politiquement c'est vraiment sur de
paisibles camps on n'en parle pas mais
c'est politique c'est culturel
si différentes il ya des potes c'est un
pas qu'elle change de des polices est
une instance politique québécois arrêtés
c'est important que la nahdha que les
résidents que des chansons françaises
puissent se développer chez je te
comprends
[Rires]
mais je crois qu'on avait quelque chose
de c'était si je peux me permettre le
fait français
moi je me souviens c'est très clair dans
ma tête après la tournée de l'état
d'après super g
on est dans une compagnie aux états unis
on est assis serge là on nous déroule un
pont d'or
je vous le dis honnêtement il ya un
pendant à des millions de dollars c'est
pas une farce et la condition c'était
qu'on le traduisent comptes traduisent
les stades en anglais et la décision
s'est regardé bondi never mais ça c'est
le fait français
puis le fait français nous tient à coeur
puis le message de nous et ali tout seul
on est tout seul c'est un message pour
moi qui devenu possiblement politique
mais un message politique derrière fois
la fin la fin du groupe vient de l'eau
parce que la moitié du bas ne voulait
pas comment sa maman l'année par tous
notamment les phares n'a pas de quoi
manger n'ont jamais cru ça mais ça a été
c'était la fête basque
[Musique]
[Rires]
allez nous ne ferons pas
pourquoi
[Musique]